[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur tv soixante dix
huit pour le sais tu ce week-end votre
émission pour être au fait de
l'actualité yvelinoise connaître aussi
les idées de sorties à faire ce week-end
dans lé département voici le programme
de ce 8 octobre une maison d'arrêt de
700 places prévues en 2027 à magnanville
l'information a été révélée par voie de
communiqué de presse du ministre de la
justice eric dupond moretti une annonce
qui a suscité une vive émotion dans la
commune plusieurs mobilisations se sont
tenues et les élus ont voté une motion
en conseil municipal pour s'opposer au
projet
la 30e fête de la science se poursuit
avec tout un programme de visites
insolites ce samedi vous pourrez
notamment vous frotter un escape game
sur le climat du côté de gif-sur-yvette
en essonne s'est organisée par le
laboratoire des sciences du climat et de
l'environnement unité rattachée à
l'observatoire de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines et puis de la
musique jouée par des pianos d'époque
jusqu'au 13 octobre l'auditorium de
chats n'auriez de croissy sur seine
accueille les fêtes romantiques
l'événement est organisé tous les ans
depuis 1999 et ce sera au programme de
la sélection de vicente matias insisté
ban bonjour bixente jose à gori or tel
est le menu du jour toujours sur le
thème de la fête de la science on aura
comme invités sandrine le flohic pour
vient nous parler du côté de la
commanderie de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
du village de la science est également
le retour du déclic théâtre déclic
théâtre qui remet le couvert à la merise
et ce sera au programme tout à l'heure
de votre partie loisirs dans ce set 8
week-end
l actualité d'abord et cette
condamnation stéphane mirambeau écope de
12 mois de prison avec sursis l'ancien
maire de villepreux de 2008 à 2009 qui
risquait une peine ferme a été reconnu
coupable d'harcèlement sexuel par le
tribunal judiciaire de versailles et des
faits qui remontent à 2018 et 2019 à
l'époque stéphane mirambeau envoie des
centaines de messages à caractère sexuel
à deux femmes pressenti pour intégrer sa
liste électorale l'ancienne élue est
condamné également à suivre une thérapie
psychologique ainsi qu'un traitement
contre l'alcoolisme il devra verser 5000
et 3000 euros aux deux victimes pour
préjudice moral et reste inéligible
pendant cinq ans stéphanie rambo dispose
de dix jours pour faire appel de cette
décision c'est une décision une annonce
justement qui a fait couler beaucoup
d'encre cette semaine comme une c'est
une maison d'arrêt à cette actualité
c'est une maison d'arrêt qui doit voir
le jour à magnanville une commune de
plus de 6000 habitants et l'information
a été révélée par eric dupond-moretti
ministre de la justice et garde des
sceaux confirmé par voie de communiqué
de presse le site doit ouvrir en 2027 il
comprendrait 700 places il serait situé
sur un terrain agricole en limite des
communes de soins dhr et offrez ville
basse oeil mais également à proximité du
lycée est léopold sédar senghor et d'un
quartier pavillonnaire une annonce qui
n'a pas été bien accueillie par les
habitants une pétition a même été lancée
sur place à la recueilli plusieurs
milliers de signatures craintes autour
de la sécurité de l'image de la ville du
prix de l'immobilier ou encore est de
l'impact environnemental et on parle
justement de cet aspect avec stéphane
bernard qui est avec nous par
visioconférence bonjour
stéphane bern a requis bonjour kim
entend ça y est alors vous êtes stéphane
bernard le coresponsable du groupe
europe écologie les verts pour le
mantois dans un communiqué de presse
vous use inquiéter un d'une nouvelle
bétonisation à venir il ne faut pas que
ce projet voit le jour c'est notre
conviction
écoutez ce projet il est il est très mal
engagée à la fois par
il concrétise on va dire la politique
gouvernementale en matière pénale
vis-à-vis de laquelle on a pas mal de
critiques en même temps
il vit ce mur qui répond à une question
qui
répondent partiellement à une question
qui l'état lamentable des prisons et des
conditions dans le domaine de son
peuplement de saleté qui ont été
condamnés
nombreuses reprises y compris au niveau
européen et qui pose problème en libye
ou détenus comme gens qui travaillent
dans la prison au gardien riou et enfin
le choix qui vient d'être fait là
maintenant c'est celui de le faire sur
des de construire sept présents sur des
terres agricoles et c'est effectivement
le premier sujet sur lequel nous nous
sommes interrogés est élevée on vous
inquiétez effectivement de cette
bétonisation alors la maison d'arrêt je
précise cela viendrait s'ajouter à une
autre maison d'arrêt dans les yvelines
celle de bois d'arcy à la maison
centrale de poissy à la maison d'arrêt
pour femmes de versailles et d'ailleurs
pour justifier cette décision le
communiqué du ministère de la justice
parle d'une surpopulation carcérale en
ile de france on a vu le communiqué sa
fiche et si on peut leur est affichée
s'il vous plaît du côté de la régie
merci et on parle d'une région
particulièrement touchée par la
surpopulation carcérale à l'image des
100 61% à 2 surpopulation à bois d'arcy
c'est une vraie problématique stéphane
bernard cette surpopulation carcérale
comment on peut y répondre justement
nous construisons pas forcément de
nouvelles de nouvelles maisons d'arrêt
comment y répondre
alors on peut y répondre déjà en
modifiant l'ensemble de la politique
pénale la petite pénale elle s'appuie
sur trois sur trois aspects des
conditions sociales d'un certain type de
délinquance qui existent et qui remplit
très largement les prisons d'autre part
les conditions dans lequel s'effectue la
réparation aussi bien pour les les
détenus condamnés mais aussi sa des
conséquences il ya bien sûr pour les
victimes des de cette délinquance et
enfin les conditions de la réinsertion
donc ces trois éléments sont liés et ça
ne peut pas se résoudre simplement par
une augmentation du nombre de places
alors maintenant c'est vrai il ya des
mauvaises jeudi tout à l'heure il ya des
mauvaises conditions dans de très très
nombreuses au plagiat que 65 68 mille
détenus aujourd'hui pour soixante mille
places on voit bien que la ja
ya un problème donc ça nous sommes tout
à fait conscients de ça et c'est pas une
fuite en avant dans l'augmentation du
nombre de places c'est traiter
l'ensemble de ces questions de
délinquance et de réparation ai je fait
que ça soit fait dans des conditions
décentes alors maintenant
il y a des tas d'endroits qui sont des
ddv zone désindustrialisé qui on est et
qui sont abandonnés il ya des tas
d'endroits où on doit où on peut
utiliser des terrains si absolument
besoin pour améliorer les conditions
dans les prisons mais aujourd'hui si on
croit réellement à ce qu'on dit sur le
réchauffement climatique
il est extrêmement important aujourd'hui
d'arrêt était d'artificial ise les sols
et en particulier en ile de france où il
ya besoin de terres agricoles il ya un
mouvement aujourd'hui qui va vers la
renaissance de zone maraîchère et voilà
il donc c'est que c'est quelque chose
qui doit être pris en compte de façon
absolument prioritaire et on y revenir
sur stéphane bern sur mobilisation je le
disais se sont tenues un depuis
l'annnonce de et bien l'apparition de
cette maison d'arrêt il y avait même une
délégation puisque ya une mobilisation
qui s'est tenue mardi soir juste avant
le conseil municipal de magnanville une
délégation a été reçue par le maire
michel le goût qu'une motion a
d'ailleurs été adoptée à l'unanimité au
cours de ce conseil pour se positionner
à contre ce projet du ministère de la
justice alors dans un communiqué de
presse le maire de magnanville dit avoir
été victime d'un déferlement sur les
réseaux sociaux suite à cette annonce il
se défend d'avoir donné son aval au
projet et à aucun moment l'état n'a
consulté les élus c'est ce que dit elle
le maire de magnanville une maison
d'arrêt qui serait construite dans une
commune sans l'aval justement d'une
municipalité ça paraît invraisemblable
quand même
ça paraît tout à fait invraisemblable et
d'ailleurs il ya eu de nombreuses
contradictions dans les déclarations de
michèle lebouc à certains moments il dit
qu'il était il admet qu'il était au
courant média
a été discuté à un moment ou un autre il
ya eu au moins des approches d'autre
part c'est pas le seul il ya beaucoup de
choses peu de choses se font et se
réalise dans le mantois sans que pierre
bédier soit au courant où on participe à
ce genre de choses donc je ne crois pas
du tout nous ne croyons pas du tout au
fait que ça a dit boulay comme ça d'un
seul coup et d'autre part il est
absolument anormal que au conseil
municipal de magnanville le huis clos
était déclarée et que même même une
délégation de cinq personnes
représentant les manifestants qui
étaient devant qui était quand même 400
n'a pas été autorisée à assister au
conseil municipal et l'opposition dont
notre conseiller municipal écologiste a
protesté contre sa nature elle merci
stéphane renard d'avoir été avec nous et
je rappelle que vous êtes co
responsables d'europe écologie les verts
dans le mantois et beaucoup d'élus un
d'ailleurs un pour ajouter à cette
thématique se sont également prononcés
sur ce projet une réaction notamment du
député de la 9e circonscription bruno
myle yen qui est voisine de la huitième
où est située cette commune de
magnanville le parlementaire comprends
les craintes légitimes suscitées par le
projet mais convaincu qu'il est une
chance pour le territoire yvelinois il
parle de 700 emplois directs indirects
qui seraient créés par l'arrivée est de
cette maison d'arrêt une sécurité
renforcée pas d'impact sur les valeurs
et des biens immobiliers sur ce dossier
comme les autres c'est l'esprit de
responsabilité qui doit nous animer fin
de citation voilà pour cette actualité
marquante de cette semaine mais il y en
a eu d'autres dans les yvelines est
depuis lundi ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
résumé par céline chars
[Musique]
une plaque commémorative a été apposée
au commissariat de rambouillet en la
mémoire de la policière stéphanie mot
fermée elle avait été assassiné en ce
même lieu le 23 avril dernier par un
terroriste lundi 4 octobre s'est
déroulée la nuit du droit organisée par
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines l'objectif était de
sensibiliser le grand public aux droits
et faire connaître ses institutions et
ses métiers au programme conférences
débats et lectures autour du philosophe
et homme politique alexis de tocqueville
le salon autonomie s'est tenue lundi et
mardi aux mureaux depuis cinq ans
l'événement est dédié aux innovations et
nouvelles technologies autour de
l'autonomie appartements équipés de
domotique vente et location de matériel
d'accessibilité étaient au programme le
28e festival de la bande dessinée se
tiendra ce week-end au château de la
commune de buc en attendant ce
rendez-vous le réalisateur de yakari
xavier giacometti a animé un atelier
auprès d'enfants à viroflay c'est en ce
moment la fête de la science à cette
occasion la scientifique young park ex
chercheuse de l'inra et a gagné le prix
l'oréal unesco qui récompense les femmes
scientifiques l'université versailles
saint quentin en organise également des
animations tout le week end
[Musique]
le retour en plateau de bixente mais
rien senti stevan pour la partie loisirs
dans un instant votre sélection des
idées de sorties à faire dans les
yvelines il y aura aussi votre invité et
qui répondra à vos questions avant cela
le laboratoire des sciences du climat et
de l'environnement rattaché notamment à
l'observatoire versailles saint quentin
en yvelines a organisé un escape game ce
jeudi animations dans le cadre de la 30e
fête de la science un jeu autour du
climat qui se déroulait à la carothèque
du campus et de gif-sur-yvette le
reportage de nicolas landry et de
justine brasil
donc c'est une série
temporelle de la température
ouvrage montrer à nos jours
résoudre des énigmes autour du climat le
principe de cette escale game
scientifique organisée par le
laboratoire des sciences du climat et de
l'environnement
objectif sortir de cet espace en
trouvant les indices dissimulés ils sont
sur les traces d'une chercheuse qui a
été enfermée en 2053 dans la carothèque
suite à une très très forte canicule
elle s'est volontairement fermé parce
que après plusieurs jours voire semaines
de canicule à des températures
supérieures à 15 ans 1/2 p sa
climatisation est tombé en panne c'est
aux participants de comprendre de
trouver les indices pour à sa place à
elle trouvé comment sortir et tous ces
indices sont en lien avec l'histoire du
crime à cette escale games une animation
organisée à gif-sur-yvette dans le cadre
des visites insolites du cnrs et de la
30e édition de la fête de la science
plus précisément dans la carothèque du
laboratoire des sciences du climat et de
l'environnement un lieu rempli de
mystères et d'histoire climatique la
carothèque savez un lieu dans lequel on
va stocker des carottes ici des carottes
de sédiments de sédiments marins que ça
va être tout ce qui va se déposer au
fond de l'océan au fur et à mesure du
temps dans lesquels on peut comprendre
et en les analysant des climats qui nie
les climats passés au total dix
scientifiques et climatologues le temps
d'un après-midi ont participé à cette
animation
c'était très intéressant des paysans
parce que c'est pas des endroits où on a
l'habitude de rentrer
et puis un super accompagnement dans
l'équipe sur place ça permet de
découvrir des choses en moi je suis un
déjà on peut dans le domaine des
sciences de la terre depuis que ça
m'était familier mais même sur les pas
familier c'était très ludique on s'est
beaucoup amusé
résultat ils ont réussi à sortir de la
carothèque en moins d'une heure leur
cadeau un jeu de société sur la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique pour
continuer l'aventuré écologique
pas trop triste d'avoir manqué les ce
qu'elle vienne bixente je passe mon
temps cette fois mais j'espère la
prochaine fois qu'ils seront présents
sachez que si vous souhaitez y
participer à cette aventure le
laboratoire des sciences du climat et de
l'environnement de saint quentin en
yvelines qui rattache l obs qu organise
un nouvel escalier mais ce soir ce sera
ce samedi 8 octobre à 15h alors dans le
cadre de cette fête de la science y
aussi des animations qui sont proposées
du côté de la commanderie à saint
quentin en yvelines oui grégory et ce
sera samedi et dimanche de 14 heures à
18 heures donc à la commanderie comme
vous le disiez de nombreuses animations
sont prévues et pour en parler avec nous
sandrine le flohic nous a rejoints sur
le plateau bonjour bonjour sandrine vous
êtes responsable de l'atelier des
sciences de la commanderie de saint
quentin en yvelines le village de la
science c'est demain samedi 9 octobre au
musée et dimanche de 14h à 18h alors
comment ça se présente cette année alors
le village et sion c'est un format qui
est assez traditionnel sur la fête de la
science au niveau national c'est plutôt
un regroupement de stands et la
particularité sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines c'est qu'on a à la
fois bien sûr des représentants
universitaires mais on a aussi beaucoup
de pratique amateur de quotas beaucoup
d'associations après cette année on a
un village des sciences qui réussit qui
réunit aussi d'autres propositions qui
ouvre aussi sur d'autres tableaux au
niveau justement des activités à faire
on n'aura pas le temps de parler tout
parce que le programme est très complet
il ya des ateliers de mathématiques
d'observation du ciel notamment des
rencontres autour de quatre thématiques
vous avez travaillé cette année alors le
club national cette année c'est émotion
à l'oeuvre eureka plutôt émotion à
l'oeuvre de la découverte émotion la
découverte sa 7ème nationale du
ministère de la recherche et nous on
s'en est saisi de manière
pluridisciplinaire
néanmoins on a quand même travaillé sur
un thème qui est l' écoute de la nature
et donc on a des propositions très
original sur cette question là et puis
apprendre à créer d'autres partenariats
notamment avec le cea pour présenter un
jeu sur le prisonnier quantique qui a un
jeu vidéo qu'on peut reprennent
retrouver chez soi aussi voilà d'autres
propositions qui sont très originales et
dont il ya plusieurs spectacles aussi
notamment concert jardinage sur transat
électronique qu'est ce que c'est en ce
moment alors là effectivement c'est une
proposition assez innovante donc c'est
le collectif puce muse qui propose des
concerts inspirée de la nature et qui
emmène avec un musicien qui nous ouvre
en fait d'un instrument très curieux
avec des mains robotisée et qui a parti
qui fait des compositions inspirées le
classique à part en découvrant par
exemple l'aube la pluie etc on a chacun
le sait donc ce sera que le samedi et on
a trois sessions où on emmène pendant 45
minutes dans ce voyage sonore oui donc
ce spectacle au musée c'est samedi à
14h30 15h30 et 16h30 est ce qu'il y
avait autre chose qui vaut le détour de
vous et me reparler alors moi y'a pour
avoir tout est formidable bien sûr mais
il ya effectivement à un projet que
j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle bill à qui
est le bureau d'interprétation des
langues des arbres et c'est un très beau
projet d'une compagnie lilloise qui a
travaillé sur le livre de peter de l'ebn
sur la communication des arbres ça a été
un best-seller ya trois ans qui a
beaucoup revisiter la relation à la
nature et eux ils emmènent en fait avec
une balade spectacle et un casque ils
font parler les arbres donc à travers
cette balade spectacle on a plein
d'informations scientifiques
l'air de rien parce que c'est vrai à
part d
enfin par des artistes a pas du tout des
scientifiques et c'est tout toutes les
propositions du village des sciences
sont à découvrir en famille à face on
retrouve le programme complet sur le
site de la commanderie de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines je sais pas si
ces affiches et on va avoir l'occasion
de l'affiché tout de suite donc on aura
bien sont pas tendres tout détailler
puisqu'au final le but de ce village des
sciences c'est de venir de déambuler
finalement c'est pour la famille en fête
qui est quel est le public rapidement
alors la manifestation à l'origine parce
qu'elle a 30 ans cette année elle fête
ses 30 ans elle est pour lutter contre
la désaffection des filières
scientifiques auxquelles est vraiment
pour encourager toutes les pratiques
scientifiques pour montrer que la
science est partout et donc on a réuni
ici une trentaine de stands de
propositions c'est énorme ce qui fait
qu'on a une diversité de thématiques et
une diversité de propositions pour tous
les âges
super bien merci beaucoup sandrine le
flohic donc je rappelle vous êtes
responsable de l'atelier des sciences de
la commanderie de saint quentin en
yvelines merci d'avoir été avec nous
donc le village de la science ce sera ce
samedi et ce dimanche de 14 heures à 18
heures et comme disait des tas
d'activités à découvrir sur place et
pour les plus organisés d'entre vous
tout est à découvrir sur le site la
commanderie point sky point fr c'est
effectivement à votre invité direction à
présent bixente le nom des yvelines avec
un peu de musique oui donc est ce que
vous aimez vous la musique classique
grégory beaud je suis un grand amateur
mais ça me développe un domaine delson
parce que oui si oui du 8 au 13 octobre
ce sont les fêtes romantiques de croissy
sur seine une semaine de concerts et
spectacles
voici ce qui vous attend
vous connaissez vous cette ère pour les
cinéphiles vous aurez pu l'entendre dans
le chef-d'oeuvre le pianiste sorti au
cinéma en 2002 il s'agit en effet des
nocturnes de chopin c'est en nocturne
extrêmement connu et qu'on n'aurait
jamais dû connaître car il l'avait écrit
pour simplement sa soeur il y avait
souhaité que ce soit détruit à sa mort
et son secrétaire n'a pas souhaité qu il
en fut ainsi et c'est comme ça qu'on
peut le jouer aujourd'hui et en plus là
dans une transcription pour violon et
piano une composition qui sera joué
parmi tant d'autres à l'occasion des
fêtes romantiques de croissy sur seine
du 8 au 13 octobre prochain une semaine
de musique prestigieuse sur des pianos
prestigieux celui qui est derrière moi
c'est un piano de jean baptiste
streicher qui et qui était lui même le
fils de nanette streicher qui faisait
des pianos déjà dans les années 1800 et
dont le père faisait des pianos pour
mozart dont vous voyez que c'est une
grande tradition viennoise et ça c'est
un instrument donc de 1847 celui qui est
à côté qui est un pleyel et de 1839 et
celui qui est derrière le tout petit qui
est de l'époque de mozart justement date
d'avant
1805 jours de concerts pour découvrir
l'évolution du piano au 19e siècle avec
un programme qui se veut complet
l'ouverture vendredi soir c'est avec
l'ensemble exams héron c'est plutôt
autour du romantisme allemand weber
schubert samedi ses deux concerts donc
autour de chopin de ma belle sound voilà
dès l'époque en tout cas des années 1839
1840 1850 et puis dimanche ça sera donc
tous les instruments en même temps le
matin avec une jeune pianiste japonaise
qui va développer le thème de la
virtuosité et l'après midi à 16h30 ce
spectacle autour des différents piano
avec guillaume vincent
et la fête continuera jusqu'au mercredi
avec entre autres un spectacle lundi 11
octobre autour de la cantatrice pauline
viardot dont on célèbre cette année le
bicentenaire
vous pourrez donc accéder aux différents
concerts pour des prix variant entre 15
et 30 euros mais des formules avec
plusieurs spectacles existe aussi pour
les plus mélomanes d'entre vous pour ces
fêtes qui vous touche bixente parce que
je sais vous êtes aussi un grand
romantique au fond le sait maintenant
place au premier salon des auteurs c'est
à vernouillet oui pas organisé par
l'association inverse et avec tous basés
elle à verneuil sur seine et ça se passe
dimanche 10 octobre de 10h à 18h le but
c'est d'accueillir les auteurs du coin
il y en aura huit originaires des
communes alentour donc je disais
verneuil vernouillet triel sur seine ou
encore nantes la jolie ils viendront
présenter et discuter autour de leurs
livres et vous verrez qu'il y en a pour
tous les goûts de la poésie roman
historique en passant par les romans
jeunesse pour plus d'informations rendez
vous sur la page facebook de
l'association envers et contre tous une
spécialité saint-quentinoise à présent
l'improvisation et l'association déclic
théâtre qui revient dès la semaine
prochaine oui la sixième édition sera
lancée à la mairie de trappes un match
d'improvisation entre comédiens à partir
de 20h30 avec le retour du public des
retrouvailles aussi pour nous reilhac
inouïe ce chargé de la partie 1 qu'un
pro voici son interview express
[Musique]
c'est râpé pour tommy lee qui revient
enfin on est hyper content de revenir
sur scène et rappeur pour familier en
fait c'est l'âme c'est la réunion
ddd des copains et des de la famille de
déclic et du public aussi qui est
habitué à voir des matchs
d'improvisation
des matches des matches déclic théâtre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fait que ce sont deux équipes qui se
rend compte sur les thèmes d'un arbitre
a donc à cette occasion sa sera julie
galibert l'art vite
et donc la revue propose un thème les
équipes montent sur scène improvise sur
ce thème et il se retrouve à être jugé
par le public à la fin de la rue de leur
dollar saynètes pour pour savoir et j'ai
terminé qui remporte coin
[Musique]
parce que le théâtre est une grande fête
et que la merise est un lieu idéal pour
accueillir le match d'improvisation
c'est à dire que quand on n'a jamais vu
une match d'improvisation
et bien en fait que le
le fait que nous on y colle pas de
championnat il n'y a pas d'enjeu c'est
vraiment juste pour le plaisir et la
merise est un endroit et trappes est un
endroit idéal pour venir découvrir le
match d'impro mais la trappe impro
family qui remet le couvert le 15
octobre à la merise à trabzon et parlait
tout à l'heure des fêtes romantiques un
peu de romantisme encore avec la fête
des plantes et c'est du côté de viroflay
pour ceux qui ont la main verte c'est
samedi 16 et dimanche 17 octobre
prochain pépiniéristes horticulteurs et
fleuristes notamment seront au rendez
vous pour vous proposer les plus beaux
parterres de fleurs mais aussi des
plantes de tous les horizons et même des
parfums à l'occasion pour vous de mettre
en couleur vos jardins ou vos intérieurs
à noter que certains producteurs locaux
seront sur place pour vous proposer
leurs spécialités gastronomiques au cas
où vous voudriez justement vous
sustenter à cet endroit le week-end
c'est aussi l'occasion de faire un peu
de sport bixente ya une première du côté
d'elle en cours oui une course de 13 km
grégory avec l'ascension de la colline
d'elancourt et la traversée du parc
france miniature c'est ce qui vous
attend pour la première édition de
l'élan courte championne ce trail 95% de
chemins naturel pour les amateurs ou les
plus confirmés et l'événement est déjà
un succès puisqu'il affiche complet avec
déjà six cents participants
pour courir donc ça va être compliqué
mais rien ne vous empêche de venir
encourager les sportifs qui en auront
bien besoin le départ sera donné donc
samedi 16 octobre à 17h30 grégory vous
pensez vous un petit règles de 13
kilomètres ça mais combien de temps
un trail de 13 km moi je le cours est en
jeu c'est pas moi en forme dans un peu
plus d'une heure quand même je ne cours
pas 13 km heure un petit peu plus d'une
heure en tout cas on espère que que les
personnes qui le font finiront déjà la
course espoirs fait donc après le sport
maintenant la traditionnelle troisième
mi-temps guen juste avant droit d'en
parler oui vous disiez c'est un
événement qui est complet mais il ya des
beaux spots il ya ce parc de france
miniature il ya la colline elancourt
également qui va accueillir en plus là
les épreuves de vtt lors des jeux
olympiques de 2024 ira d'ailleurs à
l'occasion de ce trail le passage des
drapeaux olympique est justement oui
vous lisiez après le sport y en a trois
traditionnelles troisième mi-temps vous
connaissez bien vous qui pratiquez le
sport en club du chêne c'est ça m'arrive
de temps en temps mais avec modération
pas besoin d'aller cette fois jusqu'à
berlin ou munich pour faire la fête de
la bière des tables et des chaises
seront installées sur la place du marché
de vernet sur scène pour la première
oktoberfest c'est samedi 16 octobre de
11h à 22h le but c'est de venir déguster
les productions locales et artisanal et
on le rappelle un l'alcool est à
consommer bien sûr avec modération bien
sûr l'idée c'est pas de repartir en
relate bien évidemment mais juste de
découvrir les petites brasseries du coin
d'ailleurs la liste des participants et
sur le site de la ville de verneuil sur
seine voilà pour ce programme complet on
espère qu'on vous a donné envie de
sortir dans les yvelines ce week-end et
pour la semaine prochaine merci bixente
pour toutes ces idées de sorties ainsi
grégory on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine j'espère un nouveau numéro moi
aussi du 7-8 week-end il y aura aussi le
retour du journal dès lundi à l'antenne
sûreté soit 118 ce sera à partir de 18h
avec justin brasier d'ici là passez un
excellent week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]